blue lake head podcast
we got conway the [ __ ] machine
ladies and gentlemen
yes what's good yo man i gotta thank you
cause
um you pulled up on me last night you in
l.a you know
we'll talk about what you're doing in
l.a a little bit later but you in l.a
and
uh you you play me two your albums
um the shady records debut
which is which is you know to be
determined when that when
when the rest of the world hears that
right right they're not going to be
disappointed by the way
and then your new project that uh
is you know [ __ ] a lot a little bit
for everybody on there man yeah yeah uh
like i said man i you know i i purposely
tried to like
go outside of you know what people like
my fans
may expect coming from me because i put
out a lot of tapes that's just like
you know i'll be in my just super grimy
wrap bag
and i'd be wanting to just keep my uh my
same chemistry my same formula with like
derringer and alchemist you know yeah
but i i [ __ ] with some
you know some different producers i
never worked with
like havoc you know what i'm saying yeah
that joined us crazy and you got havoc
out on the hook
too i have it on the hook so i wanted to
defend eric sermon real
mob deep [ __ ] eric sermon on there and
um
you know my man trezzy he you know i'm
coming i met him through like just
instagram
that's the two change record and that
beat is crazy
yeah so i just try to you know what i'm
saying try to go
with my approach a little different
that's all but um it's still the same
same same machine same you know the bars
as pressure you know what i'm saying you
know
i'm happy with it man i love it i think
it's some of my best [ __ ]
yo it's it's incredible and i think that
what
makes you you you had a great reference
yesterday when we were in the studio
talking
um i'll let you break it down when you
think of griselda as a human body
like you you said gun is the brain
yeah yeah yeah wes benny is the muscle i
forget what you said
derringer is that's the raspberry
respiratory system but you're the heart
yeah i put the emotion in it you know
what i'm saying
you know musically i put i put
you know just that fail that that you
know when you listen on my [ __ ] if you
it's like if you know you know
and if you know that shouldn't make like
the hair on the back of your neck stand
up you get goosebumps listening to my
[ __ ]
facts what i'm saying and i just feel
like daringer i call him like the
respiratory system because like
that production and that you know that's
the sound so that's like
that's the word bro you know that was
the breath that was the oxygen
and to make it all work you know what
i'm saying
the brain and and the heart ain't gonna
work without oxygen
you know what i'm saying i look at it
like that and i'm just thankful for them
duels
and so when we're talking like uh
you being so like you be in the heart of
the crew
and i feel like what what makes where
people people relate to you like you
said it's that pain in your music bro
and what made you want to be
put yourself out there and be so
vulnerable on records because a lot
because like you obviously
you know you talk about the other [ __ ]
the street [ __ ] the coke [ __ ] all that
[ __ ]
but you also i think you're you're
vulnerable in a way that not a lot of
artists allow
their fans in on like you know there's
not a lot of people who talk
in-depthly about personal life and
experience like
what made you make that decision i don't
know man i think it was
um a part of like you know the rehabbing
that i had to put myself through
after when i got shot right i'm saying i
had to overcome like
a lot of like to get my confidence back
up
to get my you know i didn't even
you know i didn't want to leave a house
and all type of [ __ ] like my parents
i just wasn't comfortable with my
appearance at that time and i just had
to
you know move different and think
different and i think you know i'm
saying what helped me being able to deal
with
you know that that uh you know being
you know depressed and all that [ __ ]
over over my appearance and [ __ ]
i think i had to just kind of like i
think being more honest
and being more transparent in my music
kind of helped me open up
almost like there's like a burden lift
off your shoulder like yeah just be free
i don't remember which record this was
conway because i listened to so many
songs last night
um but when we talk about you
speaking about your demons and your
experiences and [ __ ]
you were talking about your drinking
problem
right right on cue as i'm taking a sip
right and now i mean look at the end of
the day like we all got our [ __ ]
demons right like
you know what i'm saying like do you do
you consider yourself someone who's like
an alcoholic at all
um yes yes i'm uh
i consider myself an alcoholic you know
what i'm saying
functioning of course yeah yeah yeah
i mean like i don't know i feel like
it's levels to that word like you know
what i'm saying like i ain't
i've seen some alcoholics that are just
turning on like bombs and
right right you know why ain't no wino
you know what i'm saying but i do
you know i enjoy a nice cocktail with
dinner you know what i'm saying
i'm recording i'm in the store i'm
definitely going let me back out a
bottle of deuces something
you know what i'm saying has that how
you always have been or was that
something because obviously like you
said man like
you got shot you come out of the
hospital
you i can only imagine how hard it is to
like
like you said like you being able to
talk about it in your music
it helps you like feel free and [ __ ] but
i can imagine
you know going through some [ __ ] like
that that's gotta be like like
you gotta like like you said depression
is involved like
did you resort to like alcohol to help
you get through some of that [ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna be honest um you know
what i'm saying i used to
i used to like i said i uh
like for me like i would be drinking and
[ __ ] to try to like
so i can keep [ __ ] off my mind not be
thinking about the [ __ ] that i'll be
depressed about and like a lot of things
that
you know i've been going through over
the last couple of years you know what
i'm saying
so i just like like hide behind a bottle
kind of
mm-hmm what i'm saying but i've been
able to
you know i'm saying the best thing you
could do is just face it you know i'm
saying
head-on like sometimes you just gotta
look
look [ __ ] and look your demons in the
eyes and like you know what i'm saying
that's how you get
get past them [ __ ] get over them shits
you know what i'm saying that
so i you know i definitely
uh you know i mean gravitated to the to
the liquor and [ __ ] a little more than
usual
you know what i'm saying because it was
like i just didn't want to think about
i just wanted to forget everything and
just
you know man like just have fun just be
a fun
like because it's funny like you know
what i'm saying like a lot of people
like if they don't know me or that never
been around me
they'd be thinking like like i'm like
i'm screwed facing them or i'm like
you know yeah yeah they'd be looking at
you crazy if they don't know your story
or yeah they think yeah i'm just like
i'm on [ __ ] like i'm just this big
this mean you know what i'm saying bad
dude so
i try to like you know i'm saying drink
and joke around and stuff kind of like
the
you know what i'm saying to to you know
lighten the mood
so to speak but like i said like behind
closed doors and [ __ ] like
man it's a lot man personally it's a lot
professionally
is something now that you're kind of
known for and i and on one of the
records that i heard last night you
would say like i wonder if
essentially if you never got shot and
never had uh
the bell's palsy would there still be
murals of you
on walls right and all that [ __ ] yeah so
it's like
obviously it's a personal you know
situation that you're dealing with but
but i think you you also recognize that
like
it's a part of your hip-hop character
now
you know what i'm saying yeah absolutely
i definitely
accept it and and and and wear it
you know i'm saying more prideful like
more
you know what i'm saying more
comfortable with it you know what i'm
saying the bells palsy and [ __ ] and i do
realize
i feel like everything that comes from
god is a blessing you know what i'm
saying so
god don't make mistakes i don't make
mistakes so this was
i feel like maybe this was the blessing
that i needed because like
around the time like when i got shot
like i was i was um
i was moving different i really wasn't
taking music serious
you know what i'm saying like we was
outside you know what i'm saying so
i feel like you know i mean sometimes i
think about it like that like damn i
feel like god just
did that i mean like like almost almost
like
as a signal like look man like this you
got so much you got you so
gifted and you got so much potential and
so much ahead of you but you ain't
taking this [ __ ] serious so you know
what
i'm gonna you know what i mean what's
life like that it's crazy too
because you probably your your verse
that
you're most famous for the cow right
yeah that specific record when you talk
about your boy getting shot
right and how it was almost like a
blessing that you didn't
know who did it because you could have
went and you would have obviously
wouldn't have gotten revenge
i would have yeah and you wouldn't have
been sitting here
right right because i mean or you might
have been but you know what i'm saying
it's almost like you said like god don't
make mistakes like yo like
like you're in this position now you now
they gotta mention you you top five you
know what i'm saying right
right right you know i mean things could
have went a lot definitely
and been a lot worse so that was another
thing that helped me kind of overcome
like
you know be on some [ __ ] like man what
i'm tripping for like i'm still alive
you know what i'm saying i'm still you
know i'm good money i can still rap
i can still talk i can still walk i can
still [ __ ]
you [ __ ] yo for sure yeah i mean all
right what up what i got to be
you know what i'm saying what did uh i
was at the novel the night that hoe was
there
and uh when when you got off stage you
guys had a conversation after you did
the cow right yeah
what what was that short you know
exchange between you two was it
it was pretty much like about that like
just like man like
you know what i'm saying be proud of
like
how far you made it and like where the
[ __ ] you doing and where you taking it
to like [ __ ] you
you see what you're doing out here yeah
let them tears out let them just fall
you know what i'm saying and and and
really just asking me about after that
we was just really talking about
uh that's the song i did it um
overdose he was just like yo what's that
song you did like three songs
back that [ __ ] crazy you know what i'm
saying that that uh
[ __ ] i did with outcome is called
overdose we were just talking about that
but
it was just really just letting me know
like and it was just i needed to hear
that from somebody like him like
man like because i had broke down on
stage and [ __ ]
and all that like you know what i mean i
don't be knowing how to
like suppress that [ __ ] sometimes it'd
just be
it have to come off because it it i've
been uh like
lashed out at somebody it'll just go
it'd come out in some other way
some other way kind of a negative way
possibly yeah that's why
i appreciated hearing that from him like
man don't don't
don't don't hold that in bruh don't roll
that in like let that out man
that's real [ __ ] like let that [ __ ] out
man don't be don't worry about that you
know it's crazy as as
as as like as much as that verse
like penetrated my soul bro like
you got some new [ __ ] that is
crazy as far as like
the pain [ __ ] like man man you was
playing some [ __ ] last night that was
real real deep um
you know i i feel like uh like you you
were saying you were like yo there's so
much stuff that like
like you've been through a lot bro your
your life is crazy yeah
as far as just like a lot of tragedies
that you've had to deal with
yeah you know what i'm saying people
close to you
right you know i'm saying [ __ ] like that
um
you almost dying yourself and then even
just kind of seeing like
how hip-hop we've lost a lot of people
recently pop smoke rest in peace you
know what i'm saying
wow um and you're somebody who actually
was like
really involved with [ __ ] right
have you had a a hard time
um with you know you're moving around
different cities [ __ ] like that like
do you ever like are you i don't know if
you got problems in the streets or
whatever but is it
do you ever like biggie was super
paranoid you know what i'm saying
like you heard it in his music like when
you look like like do you ever find
yourself looking over your shoulder like
or
or just being like can you ever just
relax be in conway now that you're
you know what i'm saying with the life
you've lived
honestly no
like no i tried to
like i'm gonna keep it a thousand like i
tried i tried on
being on that type of time like chilling
and relaxing like i don't have no
problems like in the streets like no
being like right right you know what i
mean i don't be on that type of time i
was one of them dudes
that's why a lot of people in my city
like [ __ ] that's in the streets and
[ __ ] like that
kind of like like respect her move like
and look up to me because like
i was one of them dudes that put all
that [ __ ] on the back seat that [ __ ]
took a back seat to this music [ __ ]
i i like after i got shot i realized
like
you know what i mean like this [ __ ]
ain't ain't ain't what it is i
i went broke you know what i'm saying
and all i wasn't hustling i went broke
and i was just like cause i'm like i'm
not going back in the hood like i'm
chilling
i'm over here at darrington house
recording
and just working on my craft getting
better
at rapping because i was still kind of
like trying to find my lane because i
couldn't really
like well my my jaw can't really open my
[ __ ] that way i was like retraining your
way to wrestle
yeah you know what i'm saying so i'm
still getting myself together
but at the same time i already have my
mind made up like
um like this [ __ ] the streets even the
street
everything like when you're making
sacrifices man like
everything gotta if you want something
bad enough sometimes you gotta make like
some difficult sacrifices man like you
know
[ __ ] time work with my family and my
kids
of course no matter yeah that's what
anything freeze hustling being
broke i tell the whole little homies all
the time like sometimes you got to learn
how to be
broken bored sometimes like [ __ ] be
broke they're gonna be boring they're
gonna go outside they end up [ __ ]
doing some dumb [ __ ] because they're
bored yup sometimes you gotta know how
to just like man
bro hey that's a real [ __ ] man you broke
a boy just went out
you know what i'm saying but back to
what you're saying like you know i try
to
to you know remove that that
that street paranoia of knowing because
i know how the streets is the streets is
nasty
especially like for rappers like [ __ ]
in this like
[ __ ] rappers ain't safe just because
you're a rapper like you
you know there's somebody in that city
who you know yeah you might get caught
slipping
like bro i got robbed i got robbed in
atlanta bro this is this is the first
day that's or
the first the uh that tour that ended at
the novel the first show was in atlanta
i'm leaving them all
[ __ ] [ __ ] caught me lacking you know
what i'm saying
smash the door open you know what i'm
saying but
i just charged that [ __ ] to the game
cause i know how sometimes you gotta
you gotta learn when to take the hell it
is like you know what i'm saying well
you know but but that's what it is so
now that paranoia is back
now you know what i'm saying no no i
gotta have him you know i mean a 50 clip
on
because hey yo no not for nothing when
that kind of [ __ ] happens to you the
rage you feel
yeah i got the feeling too comfortable
man i'm cause i'm the type of [ __ ] like
i have no fears
and nothing to nobody like you feel me
like i know god
all the [ __ ] i've been through if i
could get through that [ __ ] i ain't
worried about no [ __ ]
or nothing happening to me so i'll be
everywhere by myself you see how i pull
up here
yeah me you know what i'm saying chad
that's it that's it i don't really move
with a gang of people
i don't have no fears and i feel like
you know what i mean i got lost in that
comfort zone
so now you know i'm back you know man
i'm back
yo situated um we was talking about
uh how you guys kind of have
have lived through so many eras of
hip-hop right and that there was a point
in time the 106 of park [ __ ] like
where you were you might not have been
necessarily making the music we know you
for making at the moment
i'm curious like the griselda
sound you and gunn
um at at what point in time do you feel
like you guys
figured that out where you guys were
like yeah this is like
because it obviously wasn't off the rip
like when you guys felt like you guys
was [ __ ] it's all it was off the rip
but we
we we got we got blinded like most
rappers
trying to chase hits seeing what's
happening yes and yeah i mean
what sound what we think people don't
like like that's what they want to hear
right right right popping some bottles
looking ring tone [ __ ]
yeah you know what i'm saying so we kind
of you know i mean deviated but the
funny thing is is like
we all family but it ain't like we never
really
like join forces like like that
until like later on in life as far as
like being a group
or a label you know what i'm saying so
everybody was individually doing their
own thing you know what i'm saying like
benny was doing him
i was doing making music and doing what
i'm doing with [ __ ] and
wes was you know what i'm saying he he
he lived down south he lived in atlanta
and he was like you know [ __ ] around
like in the streets he went you know
west to tell you like he wasn't on the
rapper time and none of that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but we all
fanning he loves hip-hop like
you know he he's you know probably your
biggest hip-hop fan just a lover of
hip-hop
so he will always just be around because
knowing how good
i am and then how good benny getting you
know what i'm saying so he would always
be
but he wouldn't rap in the ciphers he
wouldn't get on the records
he wouldn't he wasn't thinking about
that but
you know you know after that you know
that
after we we kind of figured that back
out like you know after i got shot
you know what i'm saying and west side
kind of like jumped in the driver's seat
like yo
i gotta kind of you know what i'm saying
i gotta you know because i it looked
like for a minute like i'm you know
i was paralyzed from the neck down like
almost some [ __ ] like that happened yeah
you're like yeah it was over yeah it's
over like this [ __ ] down there
took bro you know what i'm saying shot
this [ __ ] in his head and his neck this
[ __ ] paralyzed [ __ ] in a wheelchair
can't even move his jaw
you know what i mean so like wes that's
when west started doing like the hitler
where hermes won
and then by the time part two came up
i mustered up like one verse on there i
think i think it was
was that your first verse after getting
shot yeah
okay well not after getting shot but my
first verse
like for like griselda records gotcha
because all the records wasn't even
a thing when we did hitler too oh [ __ ]
and the first
actual griselda record when we thought
of it was hauling the hall of nash
um ep okay i'm saying like yo that's
gonna be the you know i'm saying it's
gonna be the first tape we're gonna call
this [ __ ] what you
you know i remember the phone call the
conversation like what you think about
calling [ __ ] gazelle the records you
know what i'm saying
no no this would be the first tape you
know i mean off to off the off the label
and it just grew from there yeah i'm
saying yo it's crazy like
i think with gun man guns got one of the
best minds i've ever seen
in the in the game the guys
just like like you were saying like he
just he's just a visionary
um is there uh he's fearless
yeah man like and and two like y'all you
know
if you want to do something he said he
gonna do it and bring it to life
and i and you guys never ever ever like
man i just feel like you guys have never
pivoted away from like why
why why you're here yeah which is a
heart which is hard to do
sometimes you gotta do what got you here
you know what i'm saying keep doing what
got you to where you at man
you don't try to don't deviate but it's
like you said it's hard it's hard to do
and that's kind of
going back to like the from king to a
guy album that's kind of what i was
trying to like steer away from like i
don't want to
i want to you know differentiate
myself from like this project from all
the other projects that i dropped
but i don't want to sound like i'm on
some corny [ __ ] right
right like you're trying too hard yeah
you know it don't sound like that at all
yeah not for sure by the way i think my
favorite line on there is
you said the only thing you need a [ __ ]
for is her address
that's pretty much it um
yo what's crazy too is when you you you
got a record you and you and fred are
kind of developing a cool little
chemistry on on records this song on
this album
caught me off guard because when i saw
you pull i was like oh [ __ ] gibbs
conway was definitely different than
what i was expecting yeah yeah yeah
talk about y'alls because i saw y'all
were out in miami together but talk
about y'all's chemistry and like
you know i feel like griselda fred you
know
black thought you know run the jewel i
feel like there's some jedis in the game
you know what i'm saying it's like
there's the jedi club royce
is one of them you know what i'm saying
but you and fred like i feel like
between fred and griselda y'all been
putting out the best hip-hop music for
the last
couple years what's y'alls relationship
and like
you know that chemistry has been wild on
record so far
yeah nah man and it took a while for the
for the record it took a while for y'all
to work together yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean that's my [ __ ] like gabe is my
[ __ ] man
you know what i'm saying i got love
forgets like every time i ever you know
been around that [ __ ] or whatever it's
like it's love
show and and vice versa like any time
you come around me i try to
you know i'm saying show the utmost love
and respect because i respect this crap
and i just respect you know the type of
[ __ ] he is you know what i'm saying
i went on tour with gabe so i gotta kind
of be a little
got a little closer with him you know
what i'm saying and to be around him a
little more than i have in the past
and um i just got to see what type of
dude he is
and you know i [ __ ] with the [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying and so it was only
right like we
we we always even before like this
record
um the babies and fools all of this tape
and [ __ ] like that like we've always
talked and kicked it and about
doing
[Music]
if y'all did a tape that should be crazy
exactly exactly so
but you know i mean it just you know
what what i'm one of them type of [ __ ]
everything ain't about rap [ __ ] all the
time
to me so like if i hit you i ain't all
the time like yo
i got a joint for you right right yo yo
i want you to i need i need a verse bro
i need this like i don't care about that
rap [ __ ] all the time sometimes i just
be genuinely just
tapping in like what i'm brought to what
you want guys gonna ask you because i
feel like in hip-hop i mean especially
y'all man like
you know there's
there's like very few actual friends
you'll make in the hip-hop business
absolutely tons of acquaintances tons of
people who
you'll dap up and you know what i'm
saying you'll see your shows you'll see
at events but like
actual friends that like if your rap
career went away tomorrow
that y'all would actually still be boys
right like who's on that list for you if
anybody
the list is short i'm gonna be honest
with you of course it is this is short
because you know i mean like you got to
keep in mind man a lot of these [ __ ]
cap so they
just sometimes they say [ __ ] yeah you
know you because it sounds good because
you ran into it
yeah let's do some [ __ ] you know man you
hitting a [ __ ] and
[ __ ] don't even answer your tracks back
but um
try to say you know rest in peace
prodigy that was probably the prodigy
was early with y'all yeah you know what
i'm saying like rest in peace to my boy
prodigy man that was my real
friend um rayquan
did the intro on the gazelle down that's
my real friend i like to consider us
like real friends
um royce the five nine for sure that's
my brother
like always love always love you know
what i'm saying
outside of any rap [ __ ] like you know
what i mean i look at it like we two are
the illest
lyricists come on man you know i mean we
only got you know one or two or three
songs like because it ain't about rap
it's genuine love
um flee lord that's my brother
um i remember which project
the felice [ __ ] he snapped on that [ __ ]
though yeah yeah flee one fleas on from
king to a guy okay
yeah yeah yeah that's right um
action bronze in the court i [ __ ] with
act mayhem loren
those are like shout out to mayhem bro
friends of mines you know what i'm
saying
yo um this is more but i can't think
right right right so if you didn't get
named don't be affected right
i'm gonna get a text damn bro you don't
[ __ ] with me like that yeah it died
i'm high right now baby um something
that
i don't know if we're gonna be able to
put out or not but you're in la
helping you were helping kanye write
some [ __ ] yeah
i'm doing a little ghost you know
collaboration
man i'm just you know i'm in a room for
the for the
for the vibe man and the inspiration
yeah all
other kanye [ __ ] aside he's one of the
greatest artists of all time um
and i'm curious how did the relationship
with you and like how did you end up
in that decision somebody else that i
forgot to know i considered kanye like a
real friend
you and kanye you would consider him a
friend absolutely well you've been
around him recently how do you feel like
is he like good it's like he in good
spirits like
he's in good spirits but it's like see i
don't know because i
i had i didn't know him prior prior to
what people would say him changing and
going
you know going left you know what i'm
saying so i don't know but just me being
around a man
i know his heart i know i know i said
that on twitter the other day i'm like
yo
you got a good heart right he he he you
know he mean
well i i'm gonna be just totally a
thousand percent honest
i feel like he just need you know some
better
some better guys in his circle you know
what i'm saying yeah i saw somebody say
like yo man like some better dude
sometimes you you gotta you gotta listen
and respect them dudes and you know that
it's all
they telling you signing questions
because they love you he's doing this
because they love you
you know what i'm saying but i just hate
to see like the all the jokes and
you know i mean the social media
ridicule man of my brother man cause
like
you know what i'm saying he going
through some things man you know what
i'm saying and
we all go through it in life and of
course i'm not you know
trying to condone or make no excuses and
[ __ ] for him but
i love that man and i'm you know what i
mean it's like when i got love for
people
even if i don't know you or whatever
like i just love everybody i got more
love in my heart than and then hate
so like i'm not here to tear and tear a
[ __ ] down and tell him what he can't do
or you know you crazy you tripping
like when he announced i was i was you
know what i'm saying um
on the ranch when he and you know he
called me and said i was in the studio
he's like yo
just check the twitter i just run it for
president
you were in wyoming right when i got
that's what and then i started seeing
like twitter you know what i'm saying
um like you know just
the ridicule and all that making fun of
that man and i just look at [ __ ] like
that's our problem man in the community
like we we we too quick to tear tear
somebody down then to kind of build them
up
i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] say man i'm
mother man build me a house on the moon
i'll be like i know that [ __ ] gonna be
fly bruh hell yeah do that [ __ ]
i'm just one of them type of [ __ ] i
ain't negative like tearing nobody down
yeah how did that initial like
connection happen because i do like
look kanye keeps you know he got pushed
around and he got sci-high around and we
got some of the greatest lyricists of
all time around
but like you specifically how did that
relationship start did he reach out his
people reach out
it was i i i really don't know if it was
like
he reached out or whatever but i just
remember
this was on that sunday after our show
at the novel
last show with a tour which was right
before everything shut down right before
march
shut down that's really my show was
march 7th yep march 8th
we went to sunday service that morning i
remember that
yeah i remember and he
seen us in a crowd look like oh you know
what man
so after this joint you know what i mean
bring us in the back of this [ __ ] or
whatever
and we just sit in there and kanye he's
a real sporadic like you know
you know dude like that like he's just
like you know man we need to go to cabo
and just record
all this energy right now i looked in
the crowd i see y'all there
you know i mean like we just need to all
just get on the jet just go to cobble
you know i mean benny looking at each
other like [ __ ] [ __ ] ain't we
we got warrants
so we ended up going we literally ended
up going to wyoming the next morning
so the next morning so tour ends soar
ends next morning we go to sunday
service
next morning we fly into wyoming
wow
yeah he came um like because i remember
he
he had like a meeting with with with
guys yeah he had some other [ __ ] yeah
she didn't met us out there but me and
benny was already out there
wow so let me ask you this like y'all
over some
first of all obviously you helping him
with
with with creating records but is there
going to be any sort of
i don't know if is there is there any
kanye records where you
or benny are on the record with him that
exists
not saying they're ever going to come
out
oh man i mean you went to wyoming
i know i'm gonna get a phone call soon
man i mean
but i'm gonna keep it a hunting long
there is one there's there's a record
benny's not on it but i was in the room
i'm with the [ __ ] you feel me and he
like yeah
like i want to just keep your verse on
there
and have wes still wanted then i do the
third verse type [ __ ]
yo it's wild because like you know [ __ ]
that wyoming
thing is real like you know push came
out of the other side of wyoming with
daytona
yeah was there something about being in
the middle of nowhere like that that was
inspiring your creative process because
you know that [ __ ] is in the middle of
nowhere like
jackson hole or whatever it is man cause
it's so peace and tranquil
right so peaceful and tranquil man that
you just ain't got no time
to do nothing but kind of your mind is
kind of opened up
you know i'm saying so yeah man
it's inspiring especially just to be you
know
you know initially it's just you got to
get over the nerves or like you know
it's kanye right here like you know what
i'm saying like he we
in the same you know like you kanye west
yeah i mean we sitting here like that
so you know i still look at like i'm an
up-and-coming [ __ ] in the game so
there's moments like that i'll be
on my like oh man you've had a few of
those first day
was kind of like i i was kind of like i
had a bad game if we
talking sports terms okay but the next
day
i did like maybe like two or three songs
then the next day the more comfortable i
got the more you know what i'm saying
because it's like
it's it's different atmosphere than the
type of studio atmosphere that you're
used to
you know right right like there's no
cussing ain't nobody cussing ain't no
smoking no drinking or none of that
this world just it's good energy though
it's great energy like i mean were you
on your jesus [ __ ] when you was rapping
yeah
okay yeah yeah so he took you to a
different place because i'm like yo you
you're on that
you talking that talk you know what i'm
saying
you know what i'm saying i kind of just
i found a way to kind of just make it
like to where i was just thankful
for even having a second chance at life
and to be in this position
because i you know [ __ ] like i said i
could have been left i could have died
when i got shot so
i just you know talked about
those times where like you know i feel
like god
was there for me i mean you guys have
had
m with obviously you guys did the shady
situation yeah yeah
hov yeah now yay uh i'll be damned if
the buffalo boys ain't i ain't on to
something right right yeah
this [ __ ] is crazy yo man quick break in
the podcast to tell you about our
sponsor odd socks all right make sure
you go to odd socksofficial.com
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev and you'll
save 20
when you check out they got crazy
licenses on socks they got man listen
let's pull out these ric flair joints
all right they got ric flair wwe
nickelodeon
how about some chucky for halloween
coming up
or just some basic joints they got the
odd socks basics line
one more time everything you need really
you need the most comfortable socks in
the world on your feet go to
oddssocksofficial.com and use the
keyword bootleg cab at checkout
and you'll save 20 off that's
oddssoxoficial.com
back to the podcast um
when you let me let me ask you something
because the
my son is my son is uh he's 14
and uh he's got the weirdest taste in
hip-hop like he loves like
the young ignorant [ __ ] but eminem is
his favorite rapper right
that's great my son too right yeah
and uh and i was like you know
my kid listens to anything i play in the
car and and uh
i played the you know i maybe seven
eight months ago was had the bang remix
on
right and obviously
eminem hopping on one of your joints
even though being signed to him
is a big deal oh yeah what is like
your approach as an mc
if you know now i and i don't even know
if you've recorded a song
knowing necessarily when you recorded it
that m was going to end up on it
but like when you know someone like that
is going to be on the record now you've
been on records with buster
i mean you've been on records with the
who's who with this [ __ ] yeah yeah
so my like and sometimes you'll record a
record i'm sure
and later on be like you know what let's
try to get this person on but when
you're approaching the record where you
know there's
and mind you your squad is all killers
but like one of them
legendary mount rushmore names do you
approach
like like it's almost like i feel like
it's almost like we're talking
basketball like being clutch in the
fourth quarter
you know what i'm saying like the
pressure is on like it's absolutely man
uh i mean i handle it pretty well
i just look at it like [ __ ] that can't
be no worse than
being in the studio and getting on [ __ ]
with benny and wes
facts like i gotta keep with them too
i gotta make sure i'm on my i can't let
off the gas pedal
so like i look at it like that you know
man i'm just like a
i'm an animal man i got animal instinct
man i'm trying to i can't
by no shape or form be the [ __ ] that
got the whackers verse on the song
like i don't care who i'm on the song
with i gotta i i
i if they ain't saying conway kilted the
hardest
i feel like you failed that was a wack
verse for me yeah
speaking of verses i saw you uh the
other day complex put out the best
verses of the year list
right and i i i i watch the
fire in the booth freestyle once a week
at least that [ __ ] to me is the best
verse of the year
yeah now mind you it is all the
freestyle yeah but god damn
yeah like um do you still feel like you
like because i mean
like you like you had a reason to
complain because i feel like
you know you are yeah i know i was god
was complaining
yeah but do you feel like you're still
slept on sometimes
yeah which is crazy to think yeah and i
just
you know i just i understand man it just
comes from
you know the where we from you know what
i'm saying i i just feel like if we was
from
like one of the boroughs or something or
a big name city
like we'd get a little more like love
from
you know our peers and you know some of
the gatekeepers before us and [ __ ] like
that
you know what i'm saying but it really
ain't fair to say because
so that's why i always say that [ __ ] too
much no more because
like man you you do the work you you get
you get noticed man the work don't speak
for itself
so i don't want to look like i'm just
like on like
like like i'm bratty or something like
man ain't talking about me
you know what i mean but like i'm just i
just i'm so
confident in my my craft dog that i know
ain't nobody
like when i see like the list which i
agree like a lot a lot of those verses
on that crazy are you
yeah i definitely agree with but like
there's no
way you know i'm saying some of the
verses i don't put out this year alone
you know i'm saying i don't put out
probably the the most output of
music this year alone you can't tell me
not one of my [ __ ] was a top verse of
the year
like but if you know that's what it is
everybody got their own opinion yeah was
that fire in the
break is that fire in the booth versus
gonna end up on an actual song because i
i i hate that i have to pull it up on
youtube every time um
a piece of it did okay so it did um
ended up on um
on uh on a flea album okay on a fleet
um i was fleeing put out this year
it was on there but um yeah but like
that verse
i feel like um the second verse of the
front lines joint
was crazy you know i'm saying like the
way i just
addressed the whole climate right now
with the the social injustice yeah i
told you that last night
i told you that last night that jim
jones record jim jones versus
crazy too it's like you know what i'm
saying but you know people can't
can't judge what they don't hear right
that's true let me ask you this
when when um with the emergence of benny
right over the last two years then he
went from being like
you know like y'all's homie who would
come along and rap
kind of like what like rick ricky hyde
is now no that's our cousin
right shout out to rick um and now he's
emerging as like a star in his own right
um does that like
just like i wonder between all three of
y'all man
because gunn put out pray for paris
which is a classic
right you know you guys have all had
your share of timeless music how is the
competition within the crew
like is it like yo fam i i you know i
got you on that [ __ ]
yeah honestly like tito's back i got
y'all on that [ __ ]
yeah honestly yeah it really ain't no
like
um like we're not competing like
we it's not on the outside i'm sure
deep inside [ __ ] like i'm about to
kill i gotta kill benny on this right
right right right right
my body i know conway gonna come about
to kill this [ __ ]
i'm sure inside it's a competitive
you know i mean um fun competition fun
yeah
no friendly all day yeah of course but
um family
we really champion each other and just
live like we just like salute like yeah
no that [ __ ] crazy you know i mean i
think that's what's unique about charles
is like even if you i mean
you know like i remember the first time
i watched the show documentary when i
was a kid and i saw that wu tang didn't
get along
like method man and you god were
fighting on the documentary and i was
like wait what
that's why i feel like we owe reza a
little more praise so being able to put
when i watch that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] shooting at each other and all
carpet [ __ ] like residue is able to move
forward nine
dude all that nice and give us the
illegitimate
we are a huge debt of gratitude
that's facts but i feel like that's
what's unique about charlotte is like
no matter what we know when when we look
at that
at whoever's album it is there's going
to be at least that one that's got all
three all on it
and you know the [ __ ] you you played me
last night
which what which album is the spurs
record on is that verse three is on from
king to a guy yeah
that [ __ ] is crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
and now that's one of the ones where
it's just like i said like when we all
together it's like yeah i'm saying
lebron wade and bosch some [ __ ] like
that
mm-hmm and we just and that that that
friendly competition that's burning in
the inside
all of us want to be able to have a
illegal flyer [ __ ] on the joint
i think that's what makes when we do it
all together
make it best even with derringer because
dan during the competition too
like deep down the side like i can't
have whack his [ __ ] on the album
i gotta come with to come with some
crate and all three of them on and i
gotta kill some yeah i mean
[ __ ] like that but like i said man i
think that's
you know we we just all like
[ __ ] being family playing whose role
too we just love
you everything that we we do and push
each other like
when it was benny turn like you said
last two years like man
you know me and bro like nah go ahead
benny like if you look at all our
freestyles and [ __ ] like that i'll be
like yo betty
let me hear you say that man yeah i mean
what you got benny you know what i mean
and [ __ ] like that like
it was benny turn like let's go benny
yeah y'all
y'all heard up like i heard nothing yeah
benny get him
type [ __ ] so we do we we don't like that
man we ain't right
i ain't i could i ain't no sucker i
ain't no sucker like that like
i want everyone to win win eat um
the griselda album was crazy obviously
that was like such a big deal because
you guys
i mean technically i feel like you guys
were on shady for so long but that was
the official
first release i think you guys got to
have one of the illest deals in hip-hop
because you guys are getting your indie
[ __ ] off all day
but then when it's time okay you know
you could do both
which i cannot imagine a lot of people
have that kind of freedom
to run up their indie catalog all the
meanwhile be assigned to
you know eminem yeah paul
i feel like paul was you know he's
generous
when it comes to coming to that you know
i'm saying like i ain't trying to get in
y'all way or nothing
you know what i'm saying we just want to
be a part of what y'all got going on
right
but i just feel like you know they shady
couldn't be really a part of none of
that [ __ ] because
you know the samples and all that [ __ ]
like
our sound is based off like if you if
you're a day one griselda fan
you know that our sound is based off of
like danger doing immaculate
sampling and [ __ ] like that like our
beasts are so
dark and dusty and they're incredible
yeah you know what i'm saying that's how
we was able to change
kind of change the game and shift the
culture back to like
you hear a lot of where it is alchemist
beats and
[ __ ] you know what i mean [ __ ] like
that
because we kind of shifted that [ __ ] in
but
that [ __ ] we was doing we couldn't paul
and i went [ __ ] with that [ __ ] trying
to get all them samples cleared
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] but i ain't about
to hold y'all up
there with it put it out your shady uh
debut whenever it comes out is it gonna
be
mostly sample free i mean obviously yeah
yeah
it's about that's probably about 85
sample free like a lot of them being
[ __ ] you heard ain't got no samples in i
heard a record uh
you you played a record that wayne was
on
now you got wayne
to like wade was you know wade knew what
it was when he got on the record i'll
just say that
shout out to wayne yeah was that a
record like we just talked about was
that like one of those records where you
you knew wayne was getting on it when
you cut it
actually no no i had already
i had already made that joint i had
already recorded it but i didn't finish
it it was just like the verse
was on my verse and
i had uh i think yo
um wayne has sent me the uh the russian
roulette joint
for his album me and benny you know man
benny on his house yeah russian roulette
[ __ ]
and um sent that [ __ ] back and whatever
and you know in the podcast then we did
the podcast
his uh you know yeah yeah yeah and you
know
man he he he was like man y'all man i
appreciate y'all man y'all never need me
for anything
send it through y'all got something to
send it through i said oh yeah
don't don't tell me that yeah i'm saying
yourself
i'm sending it right now then i sent it
through
you know shout out my [ __ ] mac man man
my [ __ ] mac man
good dude man that [ __ ] happened man
that's my dog right there
shout out to wayne man that nigga's
incredible we did more [ __ ] too i got in
the studio with them [ __ ] out in miami
we did some more so there's some other
[ __ ] so on a hard drive somewhere
man wayne got something crazy that's a
fact
um talk about your relationship with kd
man kd i feel like has
always had such an amazing taste in
hip-hop that's the first thing i told
him
yeah i actually i dapped him up because
i went over to his house
with fred and i was like hey man all
[ __ ] aside like i've always
respected your cause i'm a basketball
guy you know what i'm saying so i got my
own opinions about
the sports [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
yeah but i was like i've always
respected your
you know your taste in hip-hop it's
always the real [ __ ] you're
like but but talk about how y'all linked
up and
was it just from him being a fan of what
y'all do or like how did that
relationship
happen yeah just i you know it started
out i guess he
you know he was he [ __ ] with the music
but you know
my guy my big brother's set free you
know what i'm saying
he he kind of like bridged that gap you
know what i'm saying he
he brought kd to one of my shows in new
york you know what i'm saying and then
from there it was just
you know we we was kind of like like
hunk out the whole night like we went
from the show went straight to the
studio
and playing them songs and from there
it's just like it was a genuine like
you know what i mean like we and i [ __ ]
pick up on the first second ring for me
when i call up you know
i was just at his house the other day
right yesterday matter of fact
yeah where's his house and and and you
know what i'm saying but he's a
he definitely a fan of the griselda [ __ ]
like even before
like set free introduced me i seen him
like post
like [ __ ] like you know him listening
like everybody is full
or black tape or something like that you
know what man and you know man but
you know i like to think set free for
you know
making that you know bridging that gap
man and
shout out to kd man that's that's that's
my dog
yo thus far in your career man what has
been um
you've had a lot of these moments but
what has been the one surreal moment
where you like really like
you've you felt like yeah i'm on like
i'm doing what i'm supposed to do like
this [ __ ] is really
like this is where i'm at i'm at exactly
where i'm supposed to be at like
everything i did in my life like led up
to this [ __ ]
because i feel like a lot you know on
the way up we have those moments yeah
yeah man i would probably say
that you know whole
um backstage you know what i mean at the
novel yeah
and that that was that hit me different
that just sat with me different you know
i'm saying
like oh i have to do that like whole
i just vividly remember like whole made
it his business like this is jay-z
yeah that's [ __ ] lakers had a game
right across the way
yep the margin then i was just so
impressed by
like i think the lakers beat the bucks
that night it was like your box yeah
you know our type of hip-hop is
different you know the crowds is
different like yeah yeah yeah
essentially you know what i'm saying you
and emery you know what i'm saying
like i was just gone by that then that
he just made his way like when i got off
stage and i'm broke down i'm crying
and you know i'm saying the fleet arms
and all that [ __ ] and that [ __ ] like
like he walked over to tell me
like he came personally to like grab me
like
me like yo bro like you know what i mean
do that that was a huge moment for me
but and up until getting nominated for
that bt best group
award y'all should've won right there
was like that was that moment you said
like yeah this one
that's where i need to be yeah now i
remember reposting that like man y'all
should have won that though
who wanted the migos yeah they didn't
even put out yeah that's why i didn't
understand yes
you know let's you know shout out to the
amigos man hey offset's a real one bro
shout out to city girl shout out to
everybody that was nominated
have you guys linked with the the migos
at all or i mean offset
i've never linked with migos um i know
offset's a real hip-hop head i
linked with like you know um like p like
shout out to p you know what i'm saying
like him and coach k came to the atlanta
show you know what i'm saying
that night wow i'm saying i know my
energy probably was a little a little
different i
just got robbed like three hours earlier
and still when like rocked that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but
shout out to pete you know what i'm
saying we end up going you know what i'm
saying we linked to them before he
pulled up to his studio
and went out with him and stuff to the
club and [ __ ] hung up
hung out with him and all that after the
uh after the show
no this was before we initially linked
up um
at the devonta davis fight you know what
was that that boy's crazy fight in
atlanta
yo i feel like i hear about him beefing
with rappers more than i hear about him
he turned up on twitter boy have you
what's your guys's relationship like
with 50 man
50 that stuff you know you know 50 was
on the project yeah which i thought was
like such an important moment i'm saying
i i i can't lie like i don't
i don't want to cap and make it seem
like i know 50 all like that right
i don't got a 50 phone number none of
that [ __ ] down whatever
but anytime i ever was around and 50
cent was around
50 cent definitely showed me love like
now i'm saying like
like arm around my shoulder type [ __ ]
what up [ __ ] laughing joking type [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and i i got mad
love for i look up to 50 loki
of course that's how he did it and did
it his way and how he just
you know i mean to take it to to where
he took it to i just i just [ __ ] with
that
and i salute that and it's crazy because
the
the last time i seen 50 was um
when he the unveiling of his hollywood
star yeah
yeah [ __ ] or whatever then like after
his speech
em was there dre was there right we go
upstairs like to like the hotel
like on the rooftop of w or some [ __ ] to
just like
do some more like photos and [ __ ] or
whatever and um
and me and western standing there
obviously we're the only dudes with like
hoodies and [ __ ] right right you know
what i mean but after he like he taking
pictures with like
dr dre right right yeah you know i mean
top dog
marshall in them and then like before
they it was all over but that [ __ ] made
sure he like
looked dead at me like yo come here nah
yeah you
look that [ __ ] come over here and
think what else you know what i mean
like that like
i forever salute that [ __ ] i feel like
y'all are the
hardest movement group wise
energy wise since g unit
uh right because it was you know i mean
i think
you know migos is one of the greatest
rap groups of all time but i feel like
energy wise their energy doesn't
necessarily match the energy i felt like
with g
unit like i felt like with g and it so
much came with that
you know the way people dressed and
there was just so much
that came with that that energy and i
feel like you guys definitely
um are the first groups or crew
whatever you want to call it click since
g unit that's giving me that
like same exact vibe and and with that
like
there's you guys are from buffalo but
i think that you guys i mean all three
of y'all sharing the king of new york
as a state maybe not new york city but
you know i've been seeing a lot of
you know [ __ ] people claiming king
of new york and i'm like yo listen man
yeah y'all got it yeah do you do you
feel like yo yo
like like legitimately like take take
yourself like but like
in new york you got there's nobody who's
[ __ ] with y'all bro
new york city that means whatever you
want to call it yeah
i mean i just look at it like
that really ain't my you know saying my
my my
i want to just be the king of rap that's
rap game like i want to be just
when [ __ ] be like you're not asking
that's the eldest [ __ ] in the game
right now that's what i'm on that's what
i'm
after so like that king of new york city
and ireland i mean
i'm i still i'ma say i'm the king of new
york too because like [ __ ]
like pin wise i do feel like of course
like ain't nobody [ __ ] with me but i
i'm not going around beating on my chest
and trying to like you know
like slight [ __ ] to say nothing like
that man i respect everybody cry respect
everybody as
men you know what i'm saying and um [ __ ]
i wish everybody the best keep striving
but
i know like how i carry myself like i'm
the king of new york i'm the king of
the the rap game you know what i'm
saying i truly believe that
when um when did you guys really decide
and i don't know if this was gone or if
this was a group but i feel like you
guys
moved in in in unison like
with just the aesthetics it's the
artwork
it's the merch everything
it's it is it's fly it's
you know it's the painting [ __ ] it's
it's dark like what
like was is that a group collective or
is that something cause i know that um
it was gun's idea to put the lady on the
griselda cover
right the lady from buffalo um but like
it was designed a lot of the cover a lot
of the covers coming up like earlier
like in our career you would design a
lot of the covers and [ __ ] like that
but it's just you know what i mean like
we're just students of the game and we
had the benefits of just being older
and being able to be around so many
different areas
of hip-hop or when we be able to watch
and learn like we've seen
everybody the best of the best come and
do it come and go you know what i'm
saying and do it
how they did it so he was able to just
you know take notes take notes and just
apply it but
you know what i'm saying we're just
different man we
we acknowledge the the fan you know what
i'm saying for sure
though so i like to think of like what
type of experience the fans
would enjoy most from an artist if it
was me
i'm saying i want to be able to have a
collector's edition
vinyl autographed by this this artist i
want to have a cassette
they don't even make cassettes no more
but this i got this cassette
right right there [ __ ] dropped to 20
20. you signed it and
it's gold and sound like that you know
what i'm saying like
i think that is what's you know
that important and that's the collective
thing
you know what i'm saying before i'd like
to cover iron and a lot of that [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying
wes definitely spirit headed a lot of
our earlier
covers like it was just designed to
cover like you know kind of like this is
what we was on like i was just like
bro you i don't be in them officers are
doing that i don't want to talk to the
[ __ ] bro
like go ahead go get us the bag bro i'm
just i'm being here in the studio
what do you feel um right now man
obviously the world's in a crazy ass
place
hey y'all got that tour off right in
time yeah
sure that's it another we had part two
like i know you guys had a whole other
a whole other run that had a cancer now
you got you guys had to cancel it
but like obviously with the coronavirus
and uh
you know just where the world is man
with with
you know obviously the murder of george
floyd um
has it's changed the world yeah um
and then now you know with with the
election coming up like
uh are like it's it's almost you said
something earlier like you kind of took
a break from the internet
it's almost like it's hard to like man
it's it's draining to open your phone
now bruh
yeah turn the news on put your phone on
like
so much [ __ ] going on it's crazy
[ __ ] in the white house and all
that [ __ ]
yeah they died on here man this police
going crazy
it's like every time i open my phone
it's like it's bad news
it's like a snack or some [ __ ] on some
[ __ ] like
that's why i don't even be really having
my phone on me all like that like
i don't want to talk to nobody like
because i know somebody calling me with
a problem or
i don't want to hear that [ __ ] man i got
my own problem i'm trying to drink away
my pain you feel me
yo another drink yeah we got more uh i
think we killed that bottle of ducey
last night
well yeah got to be the 1738 left i'm
done with my own [ __ ]
yo getting back to your uh you're
drinking you
are you on the darker i know you're in
the dark right now uh
but what is the preferred i'll drink
everything he said everything
i really just i really just start back
[ __ ] with the dark though i've been i
don't i don't transitioned over to that
42.
the 42 is that [ __ ] i [ __ ] with that
tequila man that 40 this is way smoother
yeah well yo i really ain't been
drinking all like that
i'm kind of been you know what i mean
i'm i
really don't drink all like that anymore
what's the craziest drug you've tried
because i just did mushrooms for the
first time which was wild
yeah that [ __ ] was something else
honestly the craziest [ __ ] i tried was
like some [ __ ] called
with its or some [ __ ] oh the whippets
yeah yeah one of my white homeboys this
when i was living in
atlanta it had to be a long time ago
yeah this is a long time ago
gun is trying to bring those back but
yeah yeah yeah i was i was a long time
ago
i was homeless in atlanta and i met this
white [ __ ] that's so weak it would have
been a white guy with the whip
you know what i'm saying you know it's
crazy it's like some friend racism
and [ __ ] you think that come from the
salvos like a white dude that allowed me
to man you could crash here
bro let you stay in this crib take this
whipping yeah
here try this you ever had this try it
you know what i'm saying and i tried
that [ __ ] and it was only like
30 i don't even even like i was gone
before you knew it laughing and [ __ ]
like
it was gone before i knew it but it was
just crazy because it's like
i didn't know what the [ __ ] that was
like let me see
what about what's the shittiest job you
ever had conway i worked at mcdonald's
in alabama in alabama
and like luverne alabama it's like the
country there ain't even like no big
cities
dirt roads and [ __ ] how long were you at
mcdonald's bro
i lasted about a good month more
money i would i worked in i worked at
mcdonald's i was 15. i lasted one shift
yeah it was over i tried my best
yeah [ __ ] all that yo so you bounced
around a lot as far as like where you've
lived obviously from buffalo but
why were you in alabama well you know we
have family down there
okay you know what i'm saying i was down
there me and wes was living with you
know
graham dukes you know what i'm saying
and um
[ __ ] i couldn't you know of course i
can't be no grown ass
you know what i mean living living with
somebody and not making them get a job
holding it down so we're just on alabama
just to get away like
sometimes i always just need to get away
from the streets for a little bit
that's fair and i was able to do that
with west side gun like he always would
be
you know what i'm saying thinking bigger
yeah
he just would always he he you know
he had his you know his mom's side of
the family and [ __ ] they
made sure that he didn't have to have to
grow up like
you know most most [ __ ] in the hood
you know what i'm saying so
they they really had [ __ ] going on nice
stuff
and [ __ ] like that so i would go you
know i mean when i go spend the night at
his house is when i would be able to
have some pizza or something i may play
playstation
right right um you uh you and gunn
are big wrestling guys which has been a
big i
i feel like you guys have smoked dizzy
got that bottle it is in that brown bag
in the truck
brown bag in the truck yeah go ahead
watch this now i'm saying like with the
wrap
with the wrestling [ __ ] like i you know
i give it up to dizzy and i give it up
to you guys
to really kind of uh and shout out to my
guy rosenberg
to kind of make uh wrestling cool again
in hip-hop
yeah yeah you know about a decade ago
like you would really
be a wrestling fan was like a it was
like a scarlet letter
like yo you watched that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
how how are you um how like because
right now it's [ __ ] up because there's
no
crowd like wrestlemania was so [ __ ]
strange
that's a corny with no crowd it's hard
to watch right yeah i'm tapped out see i
ain't gonna lie
like i love the wrestling [ __ ] and all
that but i wasn't like no
big big wrestling head ass [ __ ] like
wes and dizzy and then the gun is ahead
yeah he'll like he'll like travel and go
to the little indie shows
okay okay i'd rather spend more money in
something else
that's fair but um you know what i'm
saying
again that just goes with back into you
know
knowing what what a fan want like you
got to cater to the fans man
people love wrestling yeah people love
movies people love [ __ ] like that
you know what i mean like kind of like
well wu tang with the karate flicks who
don't love karate flirt especially back
then
back then yeah like in the ninth he was
listening to hip hop
uh you know at age to really understand
what [ __ ] was doing
um in 92 93 94
then you grew up in the kung fu flick
era and if you didn't you listened to
wu-tang and then you wouldn't found it
i was like yeah oh [ __ ] yeah same thing
with the wrestling [ __ ] y'all do for
sure right you know what i'm saying
that's facts um
we were talking last night you were
talking about the errors that you've
lived through and i think it's dope that
like you said like yo look we're older
like we've lived some life
yeah and it's almost probably better
that you guys
are hitting your stride now because
maybe if you would have hit it when you
were 22
23 [ __ ] might have got crazy yeah you
know what i'm saying
um but like with the errors of hip-hop
you lived through
you know i think you and i probably got
similar taste in in music i'm curious
what did what
what are your like three or four
albums of all time like if you had to
if you had a lord forbid do a bid and
you had one ipod with
yeah and you could only put three or
four projects on there what are you what
are you taking with you that aren't your
own or griselda obviously
uh we we asking like my favorite or
your favorite i think not the best
because it's two different conversations
right that's why i'm gonna declare
around your favorite hmm
that's crazy yeah that's that's
different i always get into it with
kanye people because i know his best
album is my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy but my
favorite album is late registration you
know what i'm saying so it's not they're
not the same
all right all right your favorites i
would say definitely
uh doggy style best west coast hip-hop
album ever
i agree i've been screaming 100
i wouldn't be mad if somebody said the
chronic was
but either way right i think doggy
styles
i take doggy style i like doggy style i
would take doggy style
i would say hell to skeleton nocturnal
okay i would take
it's getting tricky because um
that dead press let's get free yep
reasonable doubt for me it was written
for me
it was written all right you know i'm
saying i respect that
and then affirmative action man i gotta
say like you know the purple tape and
iron man
hey man i gotta have some woo so it's
like it's hard for me to just take
take three or four i'll be [ __ ] up you
know what's funny that you said hell to
skelter cause
you know sean price was one of my
favorite mcs
and uh and when he died man it just it
was it was it was tough because i was
such i mean i used to buy his vinyls
like i love sean price
but i feel like you in particular
there's something about
the way you deliver rhymes that kind of
as a sean price fan it kind of hit me
not saying that you're like
sound like price yeah but you feel me
like like
like the way you just maybe it's just
not giving a [ __ ] i wrote my last name
price
man this is the sean price vibes man
oh man like i feel like ruck is like
probably taking i mean it's either him
or black thought
in my opinion the most underrated mc's
you know what i'm saying like p was so
crazy bro yeah yeah
yeah uh you know what i mean i'm just
like i said man
i would listen to that i know that album
front to back
you know i'm saying i can rap that [ __ ]
word for word
you know what i'm saying and there was
some more [ __ ] that i just
uh you know i looked up to and studied
and
and [ __ ] what they cried on how they
did that [ __ ] like
i loved i loved i loved that album i
loved
held the skeleton shout out to
bernadette and rest in peace
sean price shout out to my [ __ ] rock my
[ __ ]
uh rock nest you know what i'm saying
like you uh
you you mentioned in rayquan earlier um
what about ghost you you
have you linked up with ghost at all as
far as like i wanna like like at least
having a relationship with him ghost is
my one of my top five all time
yeah like oh i never i never linked with
ghosts
like i'm saying like like you said like
no relationship [ __ ] or whatever like
the wild lake would break
i'll pull up to the studio i've been out
to eat with rayquaza right
right right right you know i mean chill
we did we party together we don't dish
it together you know what i'm saying
like ghosts i would always see him like
you know
in the trailer we like on the same deal
out of like
at festivals and stuff like when he's
like rolling loud new york
we was on the same bill i go on the
trailer out
because i you know they all know me i'm
[ __ ] they all shows love like
that's one thing i can say man about the
woo like
and i love about them [ __ ] because a
lot of time like
you know the artists that came before
[ __ ] be kind of like
stingy with that with that a lot they
don't want to let go you gotta sometimes
like man sometimes you gotta just
embrace little you know i mean the young
little homies that's coming up man like
so i i love the wolf for that because
they always like man yo y'all boys
killing that [ __ ] keep doing what y'all
doing
i love that [ __ ] each and every one of
the members
you know what i'm saying shout out to
ray yo you had a lineup on one of these
songs where he was like they say derek
jeremiah
they were reminding erin drew ariza
you remind me of somebody who stabbed
you in the face with some
scissors that [ __ ] was crazy yeah yeah
no it's
have you got because you know i feel
like rizza don't produce like that no
more but i feel like
you know that's i don't know you guys
haven't worked with rizza yet right
no not yet i just feel like that would
be great to say nothing but he
we he we we spoke you know what i'm
saying so he's tapped in
yeah about you know he wanted to you
know like yo we gotta do some [ __ ] that
is
that but wait wait do nothing yet i'm
sure i was coming i was just hoping that
that battle kind of sparked his interest
in doing rap again
oh so because he got so much other [ __ ]
going on yeah yeah i would love that's
like a bucket list [ __ ] for me
to be in the studio or reza
well from the stories i heard i don't
know this for or whatever but just the
stories i heard
like i probably wouldn't even be in the
same room with the rhythm like i'll
probably just go there lay my verse
and then this time i gotta leave and
then you hear it
it don't even sound like what i did or
what i rapped on
i mean i heard that's how you do so but
that's bucket list to work with the
wrestler
kanye was one i can check that off
eminem check that off at all
so benny said he's got some joints with
drake oh yeah
yeah yeah that that just yeah yeah like
it is just it like we're talking about
like i feel like man your bucket list
got to be getting shorter
at least the squads because i worked
with everybody man so i was like
who was the who was your who was your
first big feature
rock marciano that that shout out to rob
one of the most underrated ones yeah we
got rock martial i
wouldn't pop the bottle and all that
like we got the voice back did you have
to pay for the rock burst
ah crazy crazy right hey man he's
a uh an incredible i just man
and then like outside of that like
priors like that was just like
dick fans like crazy blew my mind was
cool g rat raced out
and when it was on koji raps i want to
say it was his last album
one of them might be the last album did
you guys um
send the verse in or did you guys meet
up or yeah we sent it in
we sent it in that's got to be crazy
yeah we did the [ __ ] we recorded that
[ __ ] in
in texas someone from the world was down
there for south by
southwest hustling [ __ ] passing on cds
that shit's got to be over
with the cove is [ __ ] i don't know how
she's like that's ever coming back
yeah no it's wild bro like did i just
don't see how i just don't see
how that [ __ ] is possible move over [ __ ]
crazy it's crazy man well look um
you got two two albums on the way
yeah two of them yeah correct
what is it like with m let me ask you
like
the process of turning the album into
eminem
does he give you a lot of feedback
is it like have you like like do you
kind of know like the [ __ ] that he's
looking for to make the album
or or you guys for the most part he he
trusts you guys creatively
i really i don't know if i i'll can't
answer that fully because i never
we hadn't handed in no projects yeah
well you know outside
right well like i know that i've played
god don't make mistakes for him in
detroit i went to his studio
in detroit and i played it for him and
paul
and um you know he had nothing to say
everything was like yo this this
[ __ ] is crazy like this this this [ __ ]
is crazy so
i've never ever heard any like feedback
or like yo nah do this change that i
think i should
rap on this beat or do this like it
never was
so i feel like you know [ __ ] he he want
us to just do what we do
you know what i'm saying yeah i remember
i we were talking last night
and i heard the album and i was like
this is perfect
because i i remember when slaughterhouse
dropped on shady
and they tried to do the radio thing and
there was a record you played last night
that
probably never come out that was on some
radio [ __ ] that was fly as [ __ ]
but i feel like you're you
like like we were saying like [ __ ] man
like
you you i think you found a great place
sonically where you could do new [ __ ]
and still stay true to yourself stays
true to your your core fan base
and not necessarily you know a lot of
cats be reaching for hits
yeah and then it's like disappointing
you'll be like dog why did you put this
stuff
right because that was reaching they was
reaching like you know
you gotta understand like the the all
the hits that came out that we consider
hits
they just didn't go in there like yo i'm
about to go man i want to make a hit
you know it's organic you don't know
what's going to be ahead
that's how i look at like you don't know
what's going to be it you got to just go
in there and make music
with your heart and not what you are you
thinking you know
nobody know you know what i'm saying
it'd be songs
that i've done tapes and when i let
somebody here
the song that i had in mind like this
the single this gonna be the one with
people here it is
[ __ ] [ __ ] with a whole
different a whole different record you
know what i'm saying
so you never know you know what i'm
saying so you've been known to do like
obviously
alchemist collab project lulu um
is there anybody else who you have
interest in
doing a collaboration project with now
that's either a producer artist you know
earlier you and you were saying you and
gibbs
kicked around the idea like who's
somebody who you want to or is there
something that's actually in the works
for somebody that
that like because um
like i said man i really i'm at the
space and now like i'm gonna be
honest man like i really don't i really
don't give a [ __ ] about working with no
[ __ ] like
i don't really [ __ ] with nobody man and
i don't really
you know what i'm saying i don't want
nobody to [ __ ] with me just leave me
alone i don't
care about working and collabing because
i don't try being
that type of artist reaching out hey man
let's do a joint man
and you know i mean take my number man
call me yeah let's do it send it through
and you know i don't get it back or i
don't get a text back and [ __ ] like
i don't play like that you know what i'm
saying so i gotta learn
to just i've learned to just don't even
expect nothing out of these [ __ ]
because
i'm gonna put my hands on one of these
[ __ ] on yeah i mean i don't
like
playing don't cap to me like just keep
it on honey just keep it a buck yeah
just keep it a buck
keep all that lip service but i would
probably
believe it or not i want to do a tape
with stevie j
word yeah okay
hey legendary producer people be
forgetting because he'd be on the tv
because stevie j is a legend legendary
goat in the box
and a monster and [ __ ] all that
all the crazy [ __ ] you heard of the
early big
and whole [ __ ] you think made that [ __ ]
i feel like it'd be kind of crazy to
hear you uh on some like damn grease
[ __ ]
or i wanna i would love to hear you and
dmx do some [ __ ] man
absolutely yo but on the flip side of
what i just said before that like i'm
really open
to like you know what i'm saying yo you
and dmx like object to working with no
[ __ ] but like i'm not
doing the reach out no more no i get
that i respect that man anybody want to
work with me man let's get it let's
let's let's work i know me and dave eats
talked about doing the tape
that's right let's get that done like i
said earlier man gabes
have spoke about that um you know i'm
saying um
but you know right now what about you
what about
i mean obviously we have griselda
project but what about just you and
benny
we talked about that a lot as opposed to
you know
we're gonna get that out soon we're
gonna get that done i feel like it gotta
happen man you know what i'm saying
for the culture for the culture for the
griselda fans you and benny
even if it's a little six piece yeah
yeah yeah
no that's gonna come that's coming
that's gonna come well look man
all right that we do conway i appreciate
your time bro
go support uh everything this guy does
you got so much music that comes out
like what
like the big ghost [ __ ] i didn't even
like see you promote that [ __ ]
i was like it just popped up on my
spotify feed i was like what is this
[ __ ] yeah yeah nah
um you know man i'll be cooking man you
know i'll be cooking man shout out to
big ghost
you know what i mean salute for even
even thinking of having me on that doing
that with me
and that was just a project he was doing
he you know i mean like you know when
you know me i need a couple verses like
let's get it man
like i said man i'm working whoever want
to work with me man i'm with it
conway the machine yes sir boom salute